we were very conscious to try and create
a different and an even better
experience for this movie on Linux it's
unbelievably immersive you know it is
incredible sound and the image is second
to none you don't watch it you
experience it 19:17 is meant to be an
immersive film it's meant to feel like
150 minutes in someone else's life and
you want to see that and the biggest
screen with the best own system it's a
huge movie it's very intimate very
character-driven but the landscape it
goes through is fast and stunning what
Roger Deakins achieved and this is
unlike anything I've ever seen before is
something special the sort of power of
it when it's played out over this kind
of landscape that IMAX can provide is
even greater than in a conventional
movie theater you're not just seeing the
letterbox version of the film it gives
you more space at top of bottom and
frame so you feel more connected to the
central characters you just feel the
walls of the trenches so close closing
in on you you know with that extra
little bit of space that the IMAX screen
affords you that locks you into this
story of these two men
Last Man Standing Sam honest-to-god is a
genius
he really is it to have a director that
has such a crystal-clear vision of the
characters the story he's trying to tell
he's very comfy I was very actors
director 1917 is a bunch of the kind of
he lists cinema makers at the top of
their game given 110 percent every day
the triumph of human spirit is what I
hope people leave with the reason to go
and see and the I max and the reason to
sit in the front row is that you're not
going to watch a movie you're gonna love
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you